le confinement l'occasion de dire
davantage pour un français sur quatre en
cas de pénurie dans vos bibliothèques la
solution peut venir du livre numérique
cette pratique gagne du terrain mais
elle a encore du mal à s'imposer face
aux livres traditionnels râlant jeu
papier mois en 1994 la lecture ne se
fait pas encore sur une tablette dédiée
mais sur cd rom
c'est le début de la lecture numérique
et à l'époque des éditeurs y croit dur
comme fer que les vieilles haines très
loin l'édition électronique va aller
très loin
mais le chemin pour y parcourir ensemble
l'histoire commence réellement juste
avant l'an 2000
la première liseuse débarque en france
elle coûte environ 200 euros et ouvre le
champ des possibles de la lecture on lit
comme un livre ça s'affiche page par
page
on a un bouton ici pour faire défiler
les pages on peut revenir en arrière si
on veut on utilise l'écran tactile pour
par exemple augmenter la taille des
caractères changer l'orientation de la
lecture
si on veut lire de cette façon là pour
autant à l'époque pas de quoi faire
trembler les libraires c'est pas quelque
chose qui va remplacer le livre qui va
faire disparaître livre papier
le rapport des gens avec le l'objet
livre le paraît parfois de je crois de
rapports charnels ça ne disparaîtra pas
il faut encore attendre pour que le
livre numérique se déploie à partir de
2010 l'offre se développe en même temps
que le marché des tablettes numériques
avec la volonté de recréer la sensation
du livre la possibilité de faillite et
donc ils ont vraiment essayé de recréer
au maximum cette sensation de toucher de
toucher la feuille de papier bon bien
sûr ça rend pas né sera jamais un vrai
livre est ce pas le but non plus ça ne
le remplace pas loin de là en france en
2011 1 % des livres vendus sont
numériques
j'ai un amour vraiment mais spontanée
pour les livres le livre en tant
qu'objet pape sy la lecture numérique se
pratique sur liseuse sur tablette et sur
smartphone elle gagne peu à peu du
terrain et en 2015 elle représente 6,5
pour cent du marché du livre
moi j'ai plutôt des livres
science-fiction heroic fantasy
voilà c'est dit il
la syrie du trône de fer en 2018
un français sur cinq disent est d'avoir
déjà lu un livre numérique sa part dans
le marché de l'édition atteint 8,42 2%
et c'est bien sûr sans compter sur les
titres piratés
[Musique]